[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hi I'm Katie and I'm Colleen and we're  the trip sisters and we're at the  Monterey sanctuary it's one of 12  underwater national parks I think we  need to shut still everybody  [Music]  so underneath us is one of the 12  national parks that are are under the  water in the United States and I have to  think it's the most diverse and dynamic  you have any number of protected and  endangered species the underwater trench  that's out in the bay here is twice as  deep as the Grand Canyon in a couple of  locations really that's what feeds all  the wildlife in this kelp growing around  us gifts food and shelter to otters and  seals and sea lions so usually here in  the kelp forests is where you'll see the  otter seals and sea lions  [Music]  you  [Music]  you